this is the hard part for most people
can you teach your body emotionally what
the future will feel like before it
happens that means you're not waiting
for your wealth to feel abundant you're
not waiting for your success to feel
empowered you're not waiting for your
new relationship with your love you're
not waiting for the mystical experience
to feel uh you know waiting for your
healing to feel gratitude that's the old
model of reality of cause and effect
wait for something outside there to
change to take away this lack of
separation or emptiness that I feel
inside me but if you begin to condition
your body into the emotion of that
future and you can become familiar with
that emotion because you could bring it
up every day and you could keep becoming
more familiar with the way you're
thinking than where you're acting and
the way you're feeling if you actually
feel the emotions of your future before
they happen you'll never look for it why
would you look for that future if it
felt like it already happened get ready
I'm telling you get ready because weird
things are going to happen in your life
the side effect of that is the
synchronicity the Serendipity The
Coincidence the opportunity the unusual
event that causes you to do the
AC there I'm talking about a real life
event
where your world is rocked and somehow
you come to the awareness the
Consciousness the understanding that
somehow you're creating this and we move
from being the victims of Our Lives to
being the creator of our lives and I
want people to experience that to prove
to themselves how powerful they really
are and people have done all kinds of
things as a result of it hey seven
Carmichael and I make these videos
because running the business is hard and
waking up every day and getting to work
when you're all by yourself is hard and
the thing that saved me that continues
to inspire me motivate me give me hope
inspiration ideas is looking at the
stories of people who've done a lot more
than me and I learn strategies I get
motivation and it gets me to believe in
myself to go off and attack the day and
so I hope this video inspires you to do
the same as well so today let's learn
how you can manifest the things that you
want enjoy
rule number two is believe in it with
Gabby Bernstein the question is
manifesting real the only answer is it's
the only real thing
because we forget that we have a
energetic state that is constantly
attracting its likeness
and that truth that truth that this is a
world made up of energy we are beings
made up of energy and everything is a
frequency that's consistently bouncing
off of one another people things even
walking into a room and back in the
studio today this studio versus the
studio next door this studio has some
[__] up energy right wolf I mean I
don't know there's some [__] up funky
happening in this studio and next door
it's like high Vibes so energy is
everything
and we have to recognize that we can be
the conductor of the world we see when
we start to fine tune our energy
and that's how manifesting is in full
form that is the answer is manifesting
real hell yes manifesting is real
because what it is simply put is our
ability to attract our energetic
likeness
and so when we enter into spaces that
don't feel in alignment we have to do
whatever it takes to get back into that
alignment right before my first
interview in this room my friend Amanda
decadine who came on for the interview
she grabbed me by the hand she said
let's just tune in because the energy in
this room is funky uh you know we have
we've we have lovely wolf here today
we've got a lot of faith in him so we're
leaning into that and everything
technically seems to be working right
now so we're going to lean into that and
I can shift my energy around what I
walked in with right here right now and
in shifting my energy I can actually
manifest a really good episode I can
manifest a really great show I can
manifest a lot of healing and support
whereas if I hadn't been in tune with
that energy if I hadn't had the
awareness of what my Energy's doing in
this moment and how I can adjust it then
I'm going to manifest more of what I
don't want I'll probably manifest more
Tech issues today I would manifest just
a low Vibe energy I would show up for
this feeling a little bit funky and
everything would feel really off so
recognizing and accepting that
manifesting is surely the energetic
reaction and response to what our energy
is putting out
is manifesting real hell yes
and is a lot more simple than we make it
but it's the folks out there that are
constantly saying things to themselves
like hey you know I'm gonna think it and
then it's gonna happen or the more I
talk about something the more it's going
to happen or if I make a vision board
something's gonna happen that is when
manifesting becomes like a game and
that's not how it works
manifesting is really accepting the
power of your energy and learning the
tools and the methods to re-align with
the energy of Joy the energy of love the
energy of Grace the energy of inner
peace the energy of Simplicity and
relaxation and in that place of genuine
Grace we have the power to start to be
the conductor of the world that we see
and co-create our reality rather than be
the victim of the world we see because
we're not caring for our energetic State
rule number three is reprogram your mind
with Bruce Lipton your life 95 is coming
from the program
your life is a printout of your programs
you just look at your life and recognize
simple fact the things that you like
that come into your life they come in
because you have a program to
acknowledge those things but
the things you wish desire want in your
life and you work hard to make them
happen you struggle you sweat over it
I'm putting a lot of effort in I'm going
to make this happen why are you working
so hard and the answer is whatever that
destination is your program doesn't
support it and you're trying to use your
conscious creative mind to override the
program I said yeah my conscious mind is
five percent programs 95 I go it's not
going to work very well at all so that's
why poor people stay poor and rich
people stay Rich yep that's right the
book Rich Dad Poor Dad that was exactly
what the whole point was if you grew up
with a programming of a rich family you
don't have to think programming is
subconscious your thinking might be
quite stupid I mean a former president
of ours was a relatively rich person but
not very smart in his conscious mind but
his program was how do I got how I got
rich by what he downloaded that from his
family okay uh and if you're in a poor
family what did you download oh lives of
struggle it's like I can't get there as
you know you can change it I say yeah
how can you change this remember I said
well there are two minds conscious is
creative wishes and desires subconscious
hard drive with a program I say the
conscious mind being creative can learn
from anything read a self-help book oh
yeah I know how to do that I said you
read the book I give you a quiz you get
a hundred and it says yeah you know this
stuff and then I say well now that you
know the stuff that your life changed
and the answer is no
I go why the conscious mind learned from
reading a book that's not how the
subconscious mind learns so our smarts
stay up here I read the book I knew the
information I understood how it worked
blah blah blah blah blah I go yeah
that's the thinking mind that knows but
I go does that translate into
subconscious it's like oh no it doesn't
because that's not how the subconscious
mind learns you want to change the
subconscious then you have to put in the
data the way the subconscious mind
learns conscious mind creative can learn
from anything you could just go aha I
just changed my mind I can do that okay
subconscious mind habit point of habit
it resists change if a habit changes and
by definition it's not happen anymore so
habits resist change and yet we have
these habits and we want to change them
I said how can I do and I say the only
way you can change the habits is the way
that the habits were learned in the
first place I go what was that I said
first seven years your brain was at a
lower vibration than Consciousness it
was called Theta Theta is hypnosis and I
go oh so what do I do I say well you you
can't just say Okay I want to go into
hypnosis hypnosis is part of a scale of
low vibration going high during the day
and then when you come home from work
the high vibration slows down and goes
to sleep at the lowest vibration so you
go through a range of different
vibrations as you're sleeping Awakening
calm conscious focused conscious you're
at work focused conscious and I go then
what you come home you calm down now
it's calm conscious and then I say what
then you fall asleep
I said the instant you fall asleep the
next vibration down is Theta I go that's
hypnosis I go yeah so I say then every
night
the moment you fall asleep the brain for
a short period of time is in hypnosis
Theta so I say so what well you put on
earphones or ear plugs and you go to bed
playing a program that you want to be
true in your life I say so what I say
you put it on just before you fall
asleep
and while you're still awake you
probably hear some of the program okay
but the moment you fall asleep conscious
Minds disconnected doesn't hear anything
coming off of the program anymore I say
but what does I say ah
the subconscious mind is in Theta record
so whatever's coming through the
earphones is not going into conscious
mind but it's now being directly
downloaded into the subconscious so this
is called self-hypnosis you have to
repeat this process because the amount
of time in Theta is relatively short
before before you hit the lowest
vibration Delta which is sleep outright
okay so every night when you go to bed
just after your Consciousness falls
asleep there's a period of record
opportunity and then we put the
earphones on play the program is called
self-hypnosis that's hypnosis you're
doing it yourself okay number two you
still learn programs after age seven you
learn how to drive a car you learn how
to play an instrument I go well how'd
you do it that way and I go repetition
habituation is practicing something and
repeating it and repeating it so many
times that the subconscious finally says
okay I got a pattern I got the pattern
and that pattern then becomes the habit
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is create a
vision board with Power sword Bieber I
wrote the book every weekend for a year
and that was a great part of my journey
of integrating those things doing the
research finding out what science could
explain the laws of attraction
but then actually it was the response to
the book that I think really hit me
emotionally that how much people wanted
a very clear pragmatic explanation of
what you have to do with your brain and
your thinking and your feeling and your
action
to bring the things that you want into
your life so I'll start with
visualization
um and vision boards I kind of the
science behind them is is quite similar
so it's basically about three processes
that happen in the brain and they are
selective filtering selective attention
and value tagging
so basically we're bombarded with so
much information and this has been the
case for a long time but if you read a
copy of the New York Times today
you would receive as much information
from that one newspaper as somebody
would in their entire lifetime 100 years
ago and even then they were overly
bombarded with information so the brain
has a natural
um filtering mechanism which is that you
don't have need to notice things that
aren't really relevant to your survival
so for example you don't notice your
clothes on your body all day
um so we need to direct that filtering
system otherwise
in a way we're still wired just to
survive and reproduce
so things that will help us to thrive in
the modern world may not necessarily be
filtered in unless we're presenting
visual images to our brain on a daily
basis or sitting down and closing our
eyes and you know visualizing the things
that we want in our life or a certain
outcome
if we do those practices then the next
process comes in which is selective
attention which is that you notice the
things that you're visualizing or you
have on your vision board it's like when
you buy a new car and then you suddenly
see it everywhere
um
so it's basically priming your brain to
notice opportunities that will take you
closer to your goals and then value
tagging is the brain's system of putting
things in order of importance and it
does this in two ways it does it in a
cold or logical way under warm or
emotional way so The Logical things are
basically the survival you know the
basics that we need to survive like roof
over our head food on the table
um and the warmer things are the ones
that we might choose to put on our
vision board so they're the things you
know our dreams our desires goals that
show that we're thriving rather than
just kind of you know surviving
so by repeatedly exposing your brain to
these images you're priming it to not
just notice but also grasp the
opportunities that will take you closer
to what you want and that's why I call
vision boards action boards because I
don't believe that you can create this
fantasy image and sit at home and wait
for it to come true I believe that you
need to be out there networking dating
whatever it is
um to get the things that you want rule
number five is practice more with
Eckhart Tolle the greatest obstacle is
probably
uh when meditation comes out of a sense
of lack or neediness so you feel you you
are deprived of something be it money or
relationship or a living situation and
you feel there's a great lack in your
life and you desperately want this to
change
and so you perhaps
use manifestation in a way that is not
likely to work when for example you
use affirmations such as
uh I want a better job I want a job with
a good income and a life situation in a
nice place and I want this and I want
that
by making these statements
uh you're actually by implication saying
that you don't have it
so you're also by saying that you are
there's a reverse side to your statement
I want and on the reverse side of the
statement I want that is the statement I
don't have
and I need
and similar things please give me if you
you pray to
maybe God maybe you pray to Jesus maybe
you pray to Buddha they do that in
Buddhist countries maybe you pray to a
saint or whatever it is or you pray to
the universe and say please universe
please give me this please give me that
that also doesn't work very well if it
works it could be accidentally who knows
but
usually that greatly diminishes your
power of manifestation because it is the
manifestation practice arises out of a
state of lack or neediness so there's no
powerful manifestation there
The Secret of manifestation is expressed
in one simple statement by Jesus and
that encapsulates all the books
that have been written on manifestation
and will ever be written on
manifestations towards one simple
sentence it says when you pray for
something believe that you
that it has been given or that you
already have it and then you will
receive it
so the important thing is he doesn't say
believe that you will receive it
says believe that you have received it
so there the secret is hiding in that
statement believe that you have received
it and rule number six the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
change your beliefs with John azerath at
the end of your day or week do you ever
find yourself worried or frustrated
because no matter how much effort you
put in to work and no matter how hard
you work your financial situation and
your financial future may never seem to
be improving you might be finding
yourself living paycheck to paycheck
right now with not a lot of breathing
room and I would imagine no
discretionary income or even time to
spend on the little things that really
would make your life more enjoyable well
what I can share with you is you're not
alone that's number one and in most
cases the real problem is not your
current circumstances what the real
problem is that most people repeat the
same patterns of thought and behaviors
over and over again and that is the
cause of what more of the same results
but they are looking for different
results and so today I'm going to show
you how to break that pattern break that
cycle now you see when you think of your
results your results are effects and so
the question is effects of what and the
answer is your results are all effects
of what you believe to be true about
yourself what you believe to be true
that is possible and it also comes down
to what are your daily habits now if you
think about what you believe Eve and if
you think about your habits that is what
is causing the effect that you may not
like right now and so a simple logical
thing to do would be to understand that
if I could change my beliefs about what
was possible and what was possible for
me specifically and I could create more
empowering habits than my result will
change and what I love to focus on
having done an enormous amount of brain
research over the last 10 years is
something called your inner game and
your inner game is comprised of
obviously your beliefs your attitude
your perceptions how you see the world
and your inner game is also comprised of
what causes you to take action and so
let me share just a little story with
you that may help you understand what I
mean
about two years ago I was at a seminar
and when I got off the stage this woman
started walking towards me and I could
see she was somewhere in her you know
50s maybe early 60s she looked nice she
was a vibrant woman she was walking
right towards me and I saw tears
streaming down her eyes and when she got
through the crowd
for a moment I thought that maybe there
was something wrong but she actually had
tears of joy in her eyes and when I met
her her name was Joni Sanderson and this
was in Perth Australia and she came up
to me she said thank you so much and I
go well for what she says well
about a year ago I heard you speak about
beliefs and habits and mastering my
emotions and really working on my
self-worth and she said to me that she
was a caregiver and that she loved
helping families who needed extra
assistance for their aging parents or
for their children who may need some
additional help in the home so she was a
wonderful caregiver but she was living
on a Widow's pension of about twelve
thousand Aussie dollars a year and so
she really didn't have enough money to
be able to take the care of her
grandkids that she wanted to to be able
to take her children on a vacation and
so I shared with her why do you think
that you're only earning twelve thousand
dollars a year and she said I don't know
and when I shared with her that she
possibly believed that that's what she
was worth and she said to me I think I'm
worth more I said well you might be able
to declare that you're worth more but if
at a deeper level of your brain you have
this feeling that maybe you're not smart
enough or not good enough or not worthy
enough
that is what is going to drive your
behavior and so what I helped Joni do
prior to her coming to me and being in
gratitude was I helped her recognize
that beliefs Drive Behavior beliefs
Drive emotions habits Drive behavior and
in order to change your results living
paycheck to paycheck being stressed out
worrying about your future even your
presence circumstances right now why not
focus on working on the neural patterns
the beliefs and habits that are nothing
more than patterns in the brain that
drive 96 to 98 of your behavior and so
she started to work on what I call a
belief and habit modification program
and while she did this she started to
see herself in a different light she
started to feel more confident more
certain and More in empowered and what I
can share with you is she at that moment
told me that she went from making twelve
thousand dollars a year as a widows from
a Widow's pension and living paycheck to
paycheck to being able to charge for her
services and she was making 75
000 a year
you have no idea what you're capable of
you have no idea you have no idea the
person you could be the things you could
accomplish the things you can do the
people you can serve you've no idea
that's why I don't like 10-year goals
10-year goals think about who he used to
be 10 years ago you know could that
person accurately with any with any
degree of certainty predict where you
could be right now now like if you're
growing and you're learning you're
improving and you're expanding
you're invested in yourself there's no
way that you know where you're going to
be in one year let alone five years or
ten years you have no idea what you're
capable of and so it comes down to
questioning everything
the question what you can and can't do
you know we're told the story growing up
of what you should do and we're told
everything right you're told when to
show up and where to go and what to wear
and what to eat and what at what age you
should get married and what kind of
career you should go into right we're
told we should do all these things
you're told you're like who you know
nobody ever thought to ask us what we
want for our lives and you may not even
know and that's okay like you may know
where you want to go next but you may
not ultimately know the Final
Destination it's awesome
you know I think if you know the Final
Destination you're thinking small apart
from having a mission you know the
mission the purpose why do you do what
you do well I want to solve the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough that's what I'm
chasing down every day
do I know where I'm going to be in a
year nope am I still making videos
probably but who knows like question
everything I want to I want people to
believe in themselves more what's the
best way to do that right now it's
through YouTube
but I think a lot of times people have
too certain of a plan and then they end
up
playing small because there's nothing
wrong with having goals and planes but
sometimes you need to jump off that if
you have a 10-year goal quite often you
need to jump off that goal two years in
because something better has come along
that actually better serves who you are
right now because the goal you set was
for who you used to be
you know if you felt that and so I'm
here at genius Network and this group of
super successful entrepreneurs that
meets once a month in masterminds and
talk about their business and pay a lot
of money to be a part of something like
this and every time I'm around people
who are who are having a high degree of
success
I always try to have them pick me apart
so when we when we do there's an
exercise called hot seats where you go
around the table and you basically share
what your biggest
what you think your biggest problem is
and whenever it gets to my turn I just
want people to ask me questions
because
your biggest problem is you don't know
what your biggest problem is
right your biggest problem is you don't
know what your biggest problem is if you
know what your biggest problem was you
can go and solve it
for for entrepreneurs for ambitious
people for you've got goals like
you don't know what the real problem is
the problem you think you have is a
problem you know the problem you think
you have yes very much is a problem but
there's a deeper problem underneath it
that you're missing
that I'm missing so this is where
question everything becomes important my
default has become instead of pretending
like I know everything and I know all my
problems that I don't know anything and
ask me questions and in the process of
asking me questions and learning about
me maybe a couple of some insight that
I've never seen before
everybody has their own way of
processing
given advice you know so I'm around
people here everybody here has a seven
or eight figure nine figure business and
people here have sold their businesses
for nine figures crazy
awesome
and so they have their own way of
processing things and asking questions
and breaking somebody down
so instead of me coming in with
the question and having them trying to
fit into my box I'd rather fit into
theirs because in trying to understand
how they process things
it'll probably make me stretch and grow
and learn
and I'm probably going to get a better
result because they're going to see
something that I don't see
and so
in the process of questioning everything
when people can break you down and
you're open to it right because we're we
hold on to our identity like no that's
not going to work for me you know even
boom got a B
I am allergic to bees
maybe I should question that I don't
feel like questioning that today though
do not want to get stung by a bee I once
got stung by a bee and uh
only time in my life I've been sung by
bee and it I was on the floor and my my
back just swelled up from the bee sting
um
anyway
maybe question everything except bee
stings how about that there's been times
when people giving me advice and it made
sense and it really fit and sometimes
when it didn't
and and even if it doesn't make sense
what I'll default in my head the saying
is this is either nothing like the
person didn't read me correctly or it's
the whole thing
think about if you're really opposed to
somebody's advice or feedback for you if
somebody gives you great advice like oh
wow that's really cool I should go and
do that cool they they met you where you
were at and you understand it
but there'll be other times when it it
doesn't feel right
and it could be that it just wasn't a
fit and they're giving you the wrong
advice or
you're so blind and this is what gets me
excited is maybe I'm so blind maybe I
believe my story so much that the thing
that you're talking about is actually
the whole thing like it's all I should
care about because figuring out how to
solve that because I'm so tied to my own
story that I'm not questioning enough
and coming back to the B Spot hopefully
it's gone I'm not questioning enough
and figuring that out becomes the the
whole unlock so a quick story on this I
did a life coaching session with
garyvee's lead coach Beth hendel and at
first I was shocked I didn't know I
didn't know garyvee had a life coach so
I was very excited to talk to her and
just like I've been explaining this
video I went through her process like
how do you ask questions what do you
want to know about me I don't want it to
be if this is a coaching session just
treat me as a treat me as a client treat
me as somebody who's going to coach what
do you need to know from my story and
how I act and I'm gonna I'm gonna be as
open as honest as possible
and what it led to was
a lot of the stuff she was saying
um was great but my single biggest
insight and takeaway was this and I'm
practicing this every single day now
the one takeaway that has honestly
changed my life
historically I've been the person who
believes in the plan
so what's my plan to get to the next
step like I want to go here what's my
plan what's my plan what's my plan so I
have the belief in the plan and I wake
up every day and I just do the plan
because I believe in the plan
I'll have some days where I don't
believe in a plan anymore like will this
plan help get me anywhere is this plan
still working like it's not working
anymore and that leads to some anxiety
for me because I believe in the plan and
when the plan doesn't work what happens
and so what I'll end up doing is making
a new plan
so I have a plan I believe in a plan
until I don't believe in it anymore
causes anxiety come up with a new plan
the following so when creating a new
plan then I have certainty in the plan
again and I'm fine and I'm rocking
rolling but there are some days
there are some days when I can't come up
with a new plan the plan I have I don't
believe in anymore and I'm racking my
brain to come up with a new plan and I
can't come up with a new plan
if I'm the kind of person who believes
in the plane and then I can't come up
with a new plan that's a really uh
stress-inducing anxiety-filled place to
be and it doesn't happen that often
but when it does and I can't come up
with a new plan especially in the moment
well what I would end up telling myself
is great things happen to me you know
what you know what happened great things
happen to you
and I would use it as a self-soothing
mechanism as a coping mechanism
because I didn't want to just stay
locked because locked in that stress and
and it would be a downward spiral
like if I believe in the plan and the
plan is not working and I can't come
with a new plan then I don't know what
to do with my life and that would create
a downward spiral I've never gone
anywhere close to depression or suicide
but that would lead to some dark that
could lead to some dark places and so
the way that I come out of it is just
say great things will happen to me great
things happen to me they already they
always happen to me great things happen
to me and I'll figure this out and that
gives me the Comfort to
move forward into the uncertainty and
then something will come that I will
solve it and what she said was garyvee's
life coach was
what you say to yourself
when you need that
self-soothing of great things happen to
you
needs to be your default state
so instead of believing in the plan as
your default State and only going to
great things happen to you when you are
at the lowest of your low
flip it to the point where great things
happen to you is the default
because that's where you're actually
your best self and I really felt that I
don't know how to do it
but even in questioning how do I do it
I just have to believe the great things
happen to me so a big part of my routine
now is is I don't know how many times
I'll I'll say that to myself feel that
great things happen to me I'm going to
put it as my new cell phone background
um it's a it's a constant reminder even
making this video is another
reinforcement of it when people ask me
what my goals are there's been these
exercises we've been doing in genius
Network here and uh I just I just keep
reminding myself I don't know I don't
have a 10 year old great things happen
to me
it's a constant reminder and I
I would I used to live it before this
awareness
I don't know like how many times would I
feel really down and low in anxiety
filled that I couldn't come with a new
plan
maybe half of one percent of the time
like really small amounts and now I'm
probably living in great things happen
to me maybe five percent of the time ten
percent of the time which is a huge jump
from half of one percent but it's still
not my default mode yet I'm still
believing a planned guy that's my
ongoing challenge to myself that's how
I'm questioning it's the willingness to
question what you're doing because what
you're doing right now has gotten you to
where you're at and if you're if you're
happy with where you're at cool but if
you want more you want to create more
you want to serve more you want to bring
more you want to help more you want more
you want to change and you have to
change and the change starts with not
just questioning everything out there
question everything in here
questioning what you believe to be true
question who you think you are
questioning for sure what you think
you're capable of
because when you can get to the root of
that amazing things can happen is your
financial Governor holding you back from
doubling or tripling your income in the
next six to 12 months now you may be
asking John what in the world is a
financial governor and I'll explain it
this way
many years ago when the car companies
were Building engines that were faster
and stronger and more resilient cars
could go 200 250 miles an hour some
maybe even to 300 miles an hour but
because of laws in Europe and the in the
United States these Governors were put
on the engine so that the car even
though it can go faster and perform even
better it was limited to about 155 miles
per hour so here we are we have these
cars that can go extremely fast but for
obvious reasons to conserve on gas to be
able to have more safety on the roads
and to keep us generally all driving
around the same speed limit we created
these Governors to put on engines in
order to limit the speed at which the
car can go at well what does that have
to do with you earning more money you
accumulating more wealth and the answer
is everything
if you understand that you have a
conscious brain that wants to set goals
but you have a subconscious mind that is
going to limit your thoughts emotions
feelings and behaviors to what you are
governed by which is your subconscious
mind
then here's one of the things that we
have discovered
we make thirty thousand dollars a year
or 50 or 100 or 500 000 a year or a
million dollars a year or more
their financial Governor is set at a
totally different setting than somebody
who's earning less so why does this make
a difference well it makes a difference
because there's a part of your brain
that chooses the goal that you want to
achieve and there's another part of your
brain that's responsible for everything
else your thoughts emotions feelings and
behaviors and so if you don't have
coherence between these two parts of
your brain if you don't know how to
remove the governor and reset it chances
are you're going to have goals and
dreams Financial ones and even lifestyle
ones that you're not going to achieve
not because you're not capable of doing
it it's just because you are wired set
conditioned programmed whatever you want
to call it to earn the income you're
earning right now and maybe a little bit
more each day each week each month
versus doubling or tripler quintuple on
your income now let me give you a
different visual for this that'll
hopefully cement what I mean let's say
you're in a room that has a thermostat
in there and the thermostat is set to a
nice and comfortable 70 degrees and you
feel nice at that temperature what
happens if you open up a window and
let's say it's winter and cold air comes
in well what happens is the mechanism in
the thermostat that picks up what the
temperature is in the room picks up a
deviation that cold air has come in the
room and what does it do it sends a
signal through the electoral system for
the heater to go on so that the room
gets back to 70 degrees that's called a
cybernetic mechanism a control and
respond mechanism that occurs in
machines that we create them in or in
animals like us so whether it's hot air
coming into a room or cold air coming
into a room any deviation from the set
program activates the air conditioning
or the heat until the program and the
room are one and the same that is a
cybernetic mechanism as I mentioned and
here's what happens in US humans if
you're used to earning thirty thousand
or fifty thousand seventy five 100 or
200 or more or you are used to a certain
lifestyle any deviation up or down from
that setting that comfort zone that
programming
kicks in your nervous system so that you
either turn up the Jets and earn more
based on what you're used to or if you
do really well for a week a month a
quarter you actually back off and
sabotage your success until you meet the
setting that you have in your mind that
is how a governor Works in a car that's
how a governor works in your brain so
if you want to double or triple your
income in the next six months 12 months
two years
doesn't it make sense that you should
reset your financial Governor the
expectation point the programming the
conditioning
well of course it does what I've seen in
my years of training whether it's sales
people or entrepreneurs or individuals
to make more money is the ones that
think that they could do it just by
gaining more knowledge missed the point
because as a part of our brain that
gains more knowledge but doesn't change
Behavior what you have to do is
reprogram your financial set point your
conditioning the expectation point and
when you do that and you create this
coherence between your goal and your
dream and your subconscious programming
that is when your behavior starts to
change that is when fears dissipate that
is when you stop procrastinating that is
when you take inspired action and you
don't sabotage the success that you are
achieving
so in order to achieve your goals and
dreams you have to reset your Governor
reset your financial thermostat when it
comes to an affirmation affirmations can
be powerful uh
and for some people they're not
and a lot of people say well you know if
the the affirmation is so powerful how
come I'm not experiencing the effect the
what scientists tell us is the average
human
speaks to themselves consciously or
unconsciously we have thoughts spinning
around in our brain about 60 to 80
000 thoughts per day some of those
thoughts are the words to the songs and
they are the affirmations
uh neuroscientist Andrew nurburg tells
us Newberg is his name I'm sorry and um
in his work that that a single word a
single word has the power to to change
the genes that creates stress or relieve
stress in our lives he's telling us that
that something within us has the ability
to shift at the very core of our
expression so we know that words are are
powerful the key to a successful
affirmation is that we must communicate
with the subconscious part of our of our
mind number one number two we must
communicate in the language that the
subconscious recognizes
and this is where uh you know you can
say
I had a friend of mine when I was
working in the corporations that had
affirmations all over his office all
over his computer screen they were on
little Post-it notes in the car we would
carpool in you know my Perfect Mate is
manifesting for me now my Perfect Mate
is manifesting for me now that was his
affirmation and I said do you say these
things he goes oh man I say I'm about a
million times a day I said do they work
for you he says Nah
you know these these things don't work
and I said why do you think they don't
work and he said look at me he says I'm
an engineer I'm a slob he said I wear
the same clothes to work three out of
five days during the week you know and
and the the bottom line by the time he
finished describing himself to me even
he didn't believe that he was worthy of
his Perfect Mate manifesting for him now
so he was saying the words
but he was not there was the the
underlying emotion and what he was
actually feeding into his his system was
counter to what those words were saying
so it's it's not enough to say the words
when we go into our most ancient and
cherished spiritual Traditions those
words are what become the prayers
and for many people I have and I know
you've heard this as well a lot of
people feel that prayer is broken that
the world doesn't work today the way it
worked in biblical times
that we have lost our power and that we
have no ability to communicate with a
greater power with god with the forces
around us and it's largely because
the secrets the Deep truth of our
relationship the fundamental physics of
our relationship to our world uh have
been minced and parceled and in many
cases deleted
from the texts leaving us with a sense
that we are essentially powerless beings
and if you are powerless then you are a
victim and if you're a victim you need a
savior and that savior is coming to us
on a silver plate in terms of technology
in terms of political leaders I will
save you if you just do these things
this is why I say I think one of the
most the most powerful acts and the most
radical act we can do is to think for
ourselves uh original thinking based
upon the Deep truth of our relationship
to our bodies and the Earth not based
upon the false assumptions of obsolete
science that permeate our academic world
right now it's one of the reasons I left
Academia it's one of the reasons many of
my colleagues who are in this genre who
are very well respected scientists have
left Academia because they were not
allowed to share with students and in
their writings and their papers what
they had found in their research that
reflects a very different reality now
it's for me it's it's a uh it's good
news it's a beautiful message of Hope
and possibility uh as a sovereign
biological being
for a system that's based on centralized
power and control it's probably the
worst news they could imagine because it
means we don't need the centralized
power and control I think ultimately
we're all better off by embracing our
own power because it frees us from the
fear of a changing world and we all know
our world my world is changing your
world is changing nor has it ever faster
than we can document it in our
classrooms and textbooks
but the change isn't necessarily bad
until we compare it to what we've known
in the past and this is where the fear
comes in
so the the new discoveries helping us to
understand
we are part of rather than separate from
our world and this is this is where the
affirmations come in so
in I was at the CERN super conducting
super collider in Geneva Switzerland
where the the physics experiments that
are revealing
what happened moments after our universe
began they recreate
the beginning of our universe and then
they're able to document what happened
then to create the laws of physics that
we are experiencing that we're living
under right now
and what they announced in 2012 is that
there is in fact a field
an intelligent field of energy it's a
subtle energy that underlies all of
creation
um before then it was a metaphor or a
lot of people felt like it was a new age
concept you know we are all one
everything is is connected or an
indigenous you know a lot of indigenous
Elders talk about this here's here's
where they got stuck
and I've gone to Scientific conferences
where they'll take their hands and
they'll say oh yeah there's that's
that's no longer controversial there is
a field there's a field out there that
connects all things and their hands go
like this there's a field out there that
connects all things because
subconsciously they're still saying
we're separate from that field right but
here's what the science is showing us
and this this was a game changer for me
uh just a mind blower that every atom
in every molecule and every cell of our
bodies in this very instant so it's not
like it's about to happen it's it's
happening right now every atom is
constantly emerging and collapsing into
that field
and what that says to us is that we are
the field it's not the fields out there
we literally are wrinkles we are
disturbances in this field this this
body
that is held in place by a conscious
awareness as long as I'm breathing on
this Earth
I am a disturbance I'm a localized
Wrinkle in that field and what that
means
is that if I want to bring about change
in my world I don't have to force a
change out there I become that change
and as I have become that change the
field is now reflecting what it is
because I'm part of the field so it's a
subtle but it's a very powerful way a
very different way of thinking you're
not you're not imposing change on the
world around you you are becoming the
change so you're becoming the abundance
you're becoming uh the love the
Gratitude the care
uh the healing you're becoming those
things and that is very different we're
conditioned to ask for them to plead for
them because we're led to feel powerless
in our lives when in fact there are
modalities of ancient prayer that were
edited
from the the religious texts in the
fourth Century by the church they took
they took out the information helping us
to understand that this this deep
relationship leaving us powerless and
and affirmations are essentially a a
form of Prayer
our prayer is a form of affirmation
however you want to look at it where we
are communicating and I want to be
really clear it's not about control it's
not about manipulation it's not about
imposing our will it's about
participating
in the way that this field unfolds and
expresses in in our lives and when you
really begin to get that shift
it's it's
powerful it's not making something
happen out there and that means you
can't blame
what's out there for your experiences I
I come from a very dysfunctional broken
family and I had to make a choice early
in life
as to whether or not I would and
Community as to whether or not I would
allow that to Define
my my experience to Define my existence
other people around me had the same
experience and they made very different
choices they today continue to blame
their environment their parents their
family their upbringing
for the sad and unfortunate things in
their lives and and that's a path it's
not right wrong good or bad but we have
a choice to make another path
and when we begin as a scientist
beginning to understand these
relationships gave me the reason to
think differently
and it also gave me the reason to test
in my life
if those thoughts are really true or not
what works and what doesn't just give
yourself permission
to want the things that you want and
unless you believe that you're worthy
and less that you practice love you're
never going to think that you deserve
the things that you want right so tell
the story
okay so I'm probably gonna I mean
I'll shorten it so the bottom line is
that so in
1990 I was a senior in college at
Dartmouth and my parents came to visit
from Western Michigan and we went to
this place called Simon Pierce which is
a famous glass blowing Mill and as we
walked into the restaurant I had an
experience
that you may be able to relate to and
that is I walked in and I immediately
saw this painting hanging on the wall
and it was about the size of a door only
horizontal and it was a Vermont
landscape
and I was drawn into it immediately like
I was no longer in that restaurant I was
standing in that field I could feel that
breeze I'd never ever had an experience
like that with a painting have you ever
had an experience like that with art no
I mean not like that not like that I
mean yeah my sense was that this is very
atypical for you very
so I
kind of lost it the the the the
restaurant was quiet and then
I leaned back and suddenly kind of back
in the moment I'm like I'm gonna own
this painting someday
it just that was what was right there
and I looked at the price and said like
three thousand dollars I'm like not
today and I went back and I sat down and
that was it but the painting never left
my mind you see there's something called
The zeigon Arc effect I always say it
wrong but it's like there's a checklist
in your brain that when you have a
moment where you're like this is
important your brain puts it on a
checklist yeah it's like a notch yes a
notch happens and now your brain as part
of the filter in the brain is always
going to be kind of scanning the
subconscious to let anything into your
mind related to that incident it can be
positive by the way like with the
painting or this is how trauma happens
too like you have this high intensity
emotional experience that notches
something in your brain and now your
brain kicks in to remember
so uh bottom line is uh
I always thought about that painting
years go by
whenever somebody would say Vermont I'd
think of the painting
I don't know why I can't explain it
never wanted a painting before was not
an art student it's going to last like
you're out collecting Arts no no no and
so I you know fast forward the story 10
years and my uh Chris and I are engaged
and we're gonna go up to Vermont to see
the leaves and immediately I'm like we
got to go to Simon Pierce I got to show
you the painting so we pull up to the
mill and we walk in and right in front
there is Boom a painting by the same
artist Gail Shepard and I'm like oh my
God it's here and we race all around the
place
and it's gone
and the funny thing was and this is the
way your brain works Chris was more
disappointed than I was
I literally turned to him and said it's
okay dude like it'd be weird if we're
still here after 10 years I'm gonna
track this thing down I actually said to
him you know what's gonna happen Chris
I'm gonna be able to buy this like 40
years from now it's going to be hanging
in the corporate Lobby of some building
and I'm gonna have to track down the
owner and pay like quadruple the money
they pay but I'm gonna own this man my
mission yes so a couple years pass and
um it's my birthday I think I was
turning 30 and Chris says uh Chris gets
a couple people too
give money and he said I could buy
anything I wanted with it so I had what
500 bucks now I'm pregnant at the time
with our first kid
I should have bought a crib or stools
but for whatever reason the zeigon arc
effect takes over and I'm like the
painting so I call the mill and I get
this guy on the phone I'm like uh you
know I want to buy a kale Shepherd piece
and I said could you send me Polaroids
and he's like sure and I tell him the
budget and he goes I'll send you
Polaroids of some of her smaller things
and she's like blowing up in the
meantime right yeah she's a very very
successful Vermont landscape artist and
so I
I I say to him you know by the way
there's this one painting
and I describe the painting I'd seen
over 10 years ago and he said well that
was way before my time but I bet Gail
will know
and I'm like Gail you know Gail he's
like of course I know Gail she like
lives in in down the road
here's her number
so for two days I paced around the
apartment with 500 bucks in my pocket
driving Chris crazy because I felt like
what am I going to say to her and I must
be a weirdo I've been stalking this lady
I've been thinking about her for 10
years I can't afford a painting you know
what who am I to buy a painting like
what the hell
so finally Chris was like would you call
her I'm gonna call her you're driving me
crazy so I call her and I start talking
a mile a minute and she was amazing
and then
um I said by the way there was this one
painting and I go and I explain this
painting there's a stand of poplar trees
down the center and a big mountain
Escape behind it and this beautiful blue
Vermont sky and geese flying information
overhead and
I could hear her thinking on the other
end of the line
and she said you know Mel I've done so
many large-scale
uh paintings over the years I'd hate to
mistake the one you're talking about but
I'll tell you what
if my husband and I meet you and Chris
at the Mill at Simon Pierce and we'll
walk all around and have lunch and I'll
tell you the stories behind every
painting and if you don't see what you
like there I'll take you back to my
studio which is a couple miles down the
river and you can look at everything I'm
working on and if you don't see anything
you like there then you can go through
all my slides and see if you can find
that painting that you saw 10 years ago
and I said deal
so a month passes we go up to the mill I
walk in we meet each other she's amazing
she's like twice our age just incredibly
cool lady she's walking around as we're
walking around looking at these
paintings Rich I've got I'm like eight
months pregnant I'm realizing
these are 10 times the amount of money
that I have
I can't afford this
like I don't I don't have this kind of
money
and I'm getting like more and more into
that imposter syndrome what am I doing
mode oh my God I'm so embarrassed I'm
meeting somebody I idolize I don't
deserve to be here right wasting her
time because she thinks she's going to
get a Payday out of this correct we sit
down
and she goes now that you're sitting
down I have something to tell you
um
she said there's only been two times in
my career as an artist
that I've done two studies of the same
peace
and your painting is one of them
it's one of a pair
she knew all along she knew all along
she was playing games with you about not
knowing which painting yeah and she said
the sister piece to the one that you saw
all those years ago is sitting in my
studio right now where it's been for the
past 11 years
I start sobbing everybody's like totally
emotional her husband's like you should
have seen her when you when she was on
the phone with you it was like she saw a
ghost so we get in the car
and we drive to the mill
and when we walk in they're in the
center of this massive kind of Barn
Studio space is an easel with a painting
taped up with painters tape on it and it
was
the sister to my painting there were
slight differences not as much movement
in the grass but it was
one of the most extraordinary
experiences of my life it was as if time
suspended and I was
standing before that painting in 1990
saying it would be mine
and there I was 11 years later
standing in front of it
and then I realized oh my God I can't
afford this
and Chris walks over and he's like
what's wrong and I'm like just promise
me someday like promise me that I don't
need a jewelry I don't need a car like
just promise me you will buy me this
thing
and he kind of leans over and goes hey
Gail how much for the big one and she
said um
Mel can have it for 500 bucks because
clearly when I was making it 11 years
ago I was making it for her
and so it hangs in my kitchen
it's on the back of the book
um this is the galley though right so
wait is it in the is it I think so yeah
yeah and
um it's a reminder every day that your
mind is designed to help you get what
you want
I never stop believing
that I could make it happen
and when you tell your mind what's
important to you
there is extraordinary science
that proves that your mind has a live
and ever-changing filter a live Network
that changes how it views the world What
it lets in what it blocks out and if you
program your mind correctly
and if you're clear about what you want
to create your mind will help you get
what you want when you have a goal in
your head it's not even a goal it's a
fantasy it's a dream when you have a
book like this you can call it your goal
book and you write out your goals and
you go through I'm just about to take
you through bit by a bit stage by stage
you go back to that but you can look at
it you can touch it you can just make it
real so remember if you do not write out
your goals as a plan and write out how
to accomplish them you don't have a goal
you have a wish you have a dream you
have a Daydream if you want to go get a
pen get a nice little book like this you
can do on your phone too you can make a
document in your computer
and be prepared to make your goals real
so let's start now get your book pause
this if you need to go and find one
create one and I want you to pick a goal
and do not even start with I want to
lose five pounds I want more money these
are what I call wishy washy girls no
if you can make your goals real you
might as well make them huge big
enormous phenomenal so if you say well I
want more money that's why I could go
hang on a minute hey I got ten dollars
here there you go you go well that's not
my goal but you said I want more money
and I learned this when I used to work
with women who were infertile that come
and go you know I just want to be
pregnant I want to be pregnant so bad if
I was just praying I go well as I look
at your notes you've been pregnant six
times I know I keep miscarrying
so being pregnant is not your goal is it
what
isn't your goal to carry to full term a
healthy robust bouncing baby to deliver
a perfect baby to be a great man yeah
that's my goal why don't you say that
because you can be pregnant lots of
times and never have a baby or you can
say my goal is to have a perfect baby
how about this my goal is to get lots of
attention for what a nervous twitch
explosive gas that will give you
attention but that's not what you want
is it nobody wants exclusive gas
so let's start with a big goal pause if
you need to
take some time open your book
and write out a big goal now you can
have a career goal and whatever I'm
going to have my own company create my
own business invent something you can
have a relationship goal my relationship
is wonderful we grow in loving and
respecting each other and you can have a
health goal
but I want you to pick one only one not
three not five not ten one goal it can
be career it can be health
can be love pick one goal
and then I want you to decide why you
want that goal so much so the first
thing is I have a goal I want to have my
own business that's my goal and now
you're going to go to a next page and
write out why do you want to have your
own business so much and the more
reasoned you can write out why the more
likely
you will make that goal real so write
down why write down as many why's as you
can remember
you can come back any time to this and
think Oh I thought of another why and
another why to leave plenty of space
take your time and when you've done your
whys go to another page and write out
who will benefit from you achieving that
goal of course you will but who who will
benefit for instance if you have your
own business
you will employ people who will benefit
maybe your kids will go to private
school maybe your business will allow
you to help your partner have their
business
the more people who will benefit from
you achieving your goal the more reasons
you have
to achieve that goal so write out who
will benefit from you achieving a Who
how and why will they benefit you're
going to buy your mama house put your
niece and nephew through private school
did you think of your mind as like the
genie in a bottle that says your wish is
my command
I want you to understand that every
thought you think and every word you say
is a blueprint that your mind body and
psyche must make real so when you write
out your goals don't say I wish I could
be rich
I long to be in a loving relationship
write it as if it's already happening I
am a millionaire I am in a loving
relationship Michael that doesn't make
sense it does make sense because your
mind only works in the present tense
when you say next year I'll have a
bikini body it doesn't know what next
year is and so you must write your goals
in the present tense I am I always I
have I do this new page is about your
discipline
how many hours a day are you going to
spend working on your goal
how often are you going to come back to
this book and look at it I want you to
write out I am
I always I have I do and I want you to
fill that in you see the best goal in
the world will not work if you don't
work and many people fail at this point
they write out a goal my goal is to be a
millionaire my goal is to be famous my
goal is to be wildly in love and I think
that's it
it's not and if you want to be madly in
love writer all the reasons why but then
you have got to put yourself in front of
the kind of person you want to share
your life with
if you want to start your own business
and you have a reason why you also need
to have the discipline to meet people
who will fund you sponsor you joint
venture with you so I want you to really
understand that the best goal will not
work if you don't work you can have the
start point
but you have to keep doing many of the
most successful people ever say well you
know I had a goal Luther Vandross had a
goal to be a rock star
and people said well you're an overnight
success he went I don't think so you
know I sang Jingles for KFC for 12 years
that's a long night 12 years and Bill
said but Luther you're singing on
television that's cool you get paid a
lot of money for KFC I said yeah but
it's not my goal and he stuck it out and
many people have got so close to success
and had to keep going and you have to
keep going so
look at your Diesel and decide you will
give more to your goal give even more
work on it look at it write it out think
about it talk about it you must be
prepared to give so much to your goal in
fact you must be prepared to be
unstoppable in the pursuit of your goal
foreign
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
Wayne Dyer's most powerful lessons on
affirmations check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there Wayne literally came from nothing
and achieved greatness the early years
of his life were difficult as his father
was an alcoholic and left his family
when Wayne was only three years old
forcing him to be put in a series of
foster homes